[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi guys
I hope you've had a great conference I'm
really excited to be speaking to you
today my clicker is not clicking so I'm
gonna use this okay so hello world I'm
Christian by day I'm a software engineer
I work at Vistaprint in the Greater
Boston area I have a bunch of my
colleagues here by night I am a total
nerd I love hanging out at meetups going
to hackathons and checking out the
latest and greatest in technology here
is an obligatory picture of me wearing a
dorky they are glasses that I'm sure in
five years people will laugh at if not
now but the thing is this picture was
taken at a hackathon and a lot of my
experiences with augmented reality and
virtual reality actually come from
hackathons I still remember the very
first hackathon that I went to that was
a VR hack and during that time was the
first time I tried the vive headset
before the hackathon I didn't even know
what a vive headset was I didn't know
what a cardboard was I didn't know what
the difference between the two were
going to this and experiencing virtual
reality for the first time was
awe-inspiring it's something that you
really have to experience in order to
understand since then I've gone to a ton
of other hackathons with a bunch of my
friends the one at the top is the
discover AR hackathon and there we
invented a way in order to do gesture
based authentication for virtual reality
spaces hollow sense was another
hackathon with using the hololens and
for that we did things like a sonar for
the blind and subtitles for people so
the versatility of virtual reality is
boundless you can do anything that you
put your mind to and it's really really
exciting living in the present the
technology that we have today is what we
have been dreaming for about four years
does anyone remember this scene from
Star Wars which doesn't have sound
anyway the idea is that
this scene came up it was the very first
representation of augmented reality in
the cinema this is one Princess Leia
asks for help from obi-wan Kenobi
and so this is interesting right because
this is decades ago and we are still not
quite there with the technology but we
have made a lot of progress so I have a
short quiz for you guys can you guess
this is called a stereoscopic photo
can you guess when the stereoscopic
photo was first made 1920 1940 or 1960
okay raise your hand if you think it's
1920 1940 1960 well you guys are all
right on okay how about this one so this
device was made in 1950 can you guess
what it was called the sense box virtual
sphere or sensorama sense box virtual
sphere Center Rama nice so if you think
about it
we've been thinking about virtual
reality and what it means to be inside
of a different world for a long time
the sensorama was supposed to be not
just vision like the the stereoscopic
photograph but it also incorporated
other senses things like sound also
feeling so for example have you ever
gone to those 4d movies where they like
show something scary on the screen and
spritz water on you to make it feel as
if it's attacking so stuff like that the
idea of virtual reality and augmented
reality is that it augments all the
first senses not just vision or sound
okay what about this device it's
starting to look a little bit more like
a cardboard is it the vision box
telesphere mask or reality glasses
vision box tell us through your mask
reality glasses listens telesphere masks
so as the years progressed these devices
became smaller and smaller and we
started attaching it to our periphery
but to our vision okay one more this is
called the VPL data suit can you guys
guess when I was invented 1980 1990 or
2000 1980 1990 2000 cool it was 1980
in the 1980s so the vpl data suit the
whole idea was that this was rigged with
motors and vibrators so that as you
walked around in this virtual world you
could feel different objects there now
it looks really doofy and it feels kind
of silly to do something like that but
the thing is stuff like this exists
today in fact one of my teammates from
one of my colleagues from university
started a company recently called hard
light VR and they do this full-on
bodysuit that you put on and as you walk
around in the virtual world it'll
vibrate across your back so that you can
feel as if you're hitting against a wall
and stuff like that so these dreams are
really becoming realities and if you
think about it there's so many different
devices on the market today this is the
vibe has anyone here tried the vibe
before okay a bunch of you guys the vibe
is a virtual reality device but it also
has a camera on the front so you can do
augmented reality so you can't see your
surroundings it comes with two
controllers and the way that this one
works is that your tether tethered to a
debt like a desktop computer so although
you can move around and maybe like a
three meter square box you can't really
move past that this one's called the
oculus rift it's very similar
it has controllers and it's also ten
tethered to a desktop then we get into
devices that allow you to move around
freely because all of the processing is
on board the device so this one is the
Google daydream and with this what they
did was all of the processing for it is
on Europe you're on your phone similar
to the Google cardboard and lastly
there's things like the hololens this
one again has all of the processing on
the device in fact it runs Windows a
Windows 10 machine running on the device
so that you can walk around the hololens
is different from these other devices
because it's augmented reality and what
that means is instead of just being able
to see the screen in front of you you
can see the surroundings and see
holograms overlaid on top of it so
that's pretty cool and have you guys
seen this in the news anyone so this is
a new augmented reality device called
the magic leaf and whether or not we'll
be walking around with devices like
these strapped to our heads
I'd like you to imagine a future of
augmented reality so in this video this
is a video called hyper reality it's a
simulation of what a shopping experience
might be if you have augmented reality
everywhere and so here there's a little
pet that's kind of like a shopping
helper that tells you what you forget
but as you look around you see that
there are ads shown on different parts
of the of the store you can see that it
recognized that those are coconuts or
pineapples and based on that it's able
to say hey you forgot this item in your
grocery cart or it's able to add
additional information about any item
you pick up now what would a world like
this look like if it crashed so here's
an example of the system rebooting and
here you can see that once the system is
off this is kind of the imagination that
they had is you have a bunch of markers
in order to detect where to place this
augmentation on top of in order to do AG
mented reality like this we need markers
in the real world that are able to tell
us where the where the device goes on
top of so it's funny that we use this as
imagination but this is two years ago
Alibaba already offers a VR shopping
experience you can put on a cardboard
headset go into the store and pick out
products that you want to buy you can
look at it and you can check out right
from the virtual store so this isn't
really the future it's already the
present there are other devices there
are other applications of virtual and
augmented reality to discover VR applied
it for an educational purpose and what
they did was if you wanted to for
example teach kids about sharks you
can't take them underwater but you can
give them a headset to take a look at a
different wildlife this idea of using
virtual reality for education is really
interesting because it gives you a new
way of processing information one of the
hackathons that I judged last year the
MIT reality virtually hackathon one of
the teams had a really interesting idea
say you have a ton of MRI scans that are
flat 2d images what if we paddled
up and stack them right next to each
other so that you can get a 3d vision of
the brain it's a whole new way of
processing data that used to be static
because now you can look inside the
human body or look inside the brain and
analyze things in a way that you never
could before
and then there's more fun applications
anyone here still play Pokemon go
Pokemon oh I have two hands on maybe
three Pokemon go maybe a year ago was
like all the rage and why was it so
popular although it was a very simple
idea there wasn't any interaction
between the Pokemon and the Saran and
its background
it made it contextual it made it feel as
if the Pokemon was actually there and
this is really easy to do right you
could do this in a web browser super
simply just use a video feed and then
overlay a div on top of it augmented
reality augmented reality does not have
to be complicated another example of a
useful product that you might think of
is Wayfarer Wayfarer came out with this
augmented reality application that would
let you visualize furniture before you
bought it because they're an online
shopping retailer they want you to be
able to feel confident in the furniture
that you buy and how it would look in
your space before you make the purchase
now this was originally written using
the Google's tango can tango enabled
devices but I believe that they've now
moved on to air core so there's a lot of
different kinds of devices that allow
you to do really interesting things
these days virtual and augmented reality
are about to revolutionize how we live
and experience the world around us if
you think about it these examples that I
showed you might seem kind of silly but
so did the first few days first few
years of the Internet it kind of feels
like the space that we're in right now
with virtual and augmented reality is
this is like 1990s we're just figuring
out what it should look like what it
should feel like and it's a really
exciting time to be in and because of
this I think it's really important to
talk about who has access to these
devices and how we can make it more
available to everyone around the
world democratizing AR means that one
everyone has access to an AR enabled
device and to anyone can build augmented
reality experiences now if you look at
so if you look at um all of those
devices that I showed you before none of
those were web-based right we had the
vibe we had the hololens we had the
oculus but the thing is if you look at
how many of these devices sold and
compared to the Google cardboard for
instance you'll see that the Google
cardboard vastly outsold all of the
other devices combined what is this
telling us people that are trying out
virtual and augmented reality for the
very first time are doing so on low-end
devices things like the Google cardboard
or on their mobile phones and if you
think about it that makes sense our
mobile phones have become so powerful
over the last few years it's it possible
to do augmented reality applications
with them so if you think about it
everyone already has access to an air
device it's in their back pockets or
phones and the second one is anyone can
build an AR experience if we make it
easy to put together an augmented
reality experience just as it is to
build a website then anyone can start
building these things by themselves so
as web developers I believe that we can
shape the future of virtual and
augmented reality by building
applications for the mobile web there
are already a lot of api's that enable
us to do this and so today I'm going to
talk to you guys about one way that we
can we can get there so first let's talk
about the present state of web and web
the yarn air so first when you think
about web vr there are a lot of
different libraries out there the most
basic of which is WebGL WebGL is if you
want to write like pure vector math in
order to develop your virtual reality
applications 3GS is a JavaScript library
that was built on top of WebGL and what
it does is it exposes higher-level API
so you can do things like create cameras
or place objects without really having
to worry about like all of the vertices
vertex math there are two more libraries
that I'm really excited about right now
one is a frame which you might have
heard about before and the other is
react 360 a frame allows you to create
virtual reality applications using a
component based architecture it like
HTML components so in order to for
example create a box you just have HTML
tags and a box it's very simple
you should definitely check it out the
AK 360 is another interesting one
especially at JS conf I feel like a lot
of us are really into react and the
reason is because it helps us manage
complex application state so if you have
a virtual reality application that has
many different components that need to
talk to each other and need to be able
to say hey like this button was quick so
turn this view on react 360 is a really
interesting choice reactor 60 offers
something that has a model that's
slightly different from a frame so it
has this notion of panels and models a
panel is basically something in 3d space
that's flat so think of something like a
paper or a post around the wall a model
is something that's three-dimensional
think of like a model of a sofa we'll
come back to this later now let's talk
about web AR so web AR is still kind of
in its infancy there are three kind of
big libraries that people tend to use
when working with web AR ojs is one of
them jsr Rico and lastly a rjs the thing
is all of these libraries so are eco and
ojs are built on top of the article so
Ericka is basically a library that was
written in C that allows you to detect
certain types of markers and figure out
what the poses of those markers so that
you can put items on top of it I'll
explain that in a second a rjs was
poured it uses a our tool kit on the
underside so those are like the two
competing frameworks right now a ijs is
pretty awesome like I think of all of
the libraries that I've used so far RJ
seems to be the one that's farthest
along you can use a rjs with
frame so for example if you want to
create augmented reality in your a frame
application there's this really easy
component that you can use in order to
add augmented reality to your a frame
application and less than ten lines of
HTML so if this is something that works
for you then definitely check it out now
looking at the slide you're thinking
okay Christina you're just telling me to
go home and check out a rjs but the
thing is I've used this before and I ran
into some problems especially because
the markers aren't very customizable
these are the markers that AR all of
those libraries that I talked to you
guys about before I use so they use the
article markers or the hero markers AR
Jas uses the hero marker and you can
customize what goes in the middle of it
but you can't customize the borders so
you still have these really thick black
borders if you want to use these markers
and while it's fine for some
applications if you want to put it on
like a poster or if you want to put it
on something that is designed it can be
a little bit frustrating to have to deal
with these limitations so that's kind of
where we're at right now with Web VR and
AR there's a lot going on and it's
constantly evolving next I want to talk
to you about QR a rjs and how you can
use it so what is curare rjs when I was
working on a project a while ago at a
hackathon I noticed that these markers
look just like you are codes and yet
they're not so the idea was could we use
QR codes instead now QR codes don't have
to look ugly snapchat uses basically a
QR code in order to share your share
contact information the one right below
that is from Twitter so Twitter also
uses QR codes and you can customize QR
codes to your heart's extent pretty much
you can change the color you can change
the corner eyelets and the dots that go
inside of it this means that if you
wanted to add a QR code to your design
and make it look use make it make it
design to fit with the rest of your
whatever whatever you yeah to make it
fit with the rest of it you can
definitely do it the other thing is
because QR codes are actually a code
is standardized across multiple
different platforms many phones already
have QR code scanners for example
iPhones have a QR code scanner in the
Chrome browser so you can just point to
a QR code and scan it and go to the
website directly so this is kind of how
standards are proliferate right I wanted
to come up with a new way of combining
QR codes with the existing AR AR
libraries so introducing QR a rjs cure a
rjs is a way for you to add augmented
reality to your applications that uses
QR codes as markers there are two
different types of models that you can
add to your applications one is a 3d
model and second is a 2d plane and this
is partially inspired by react 360s
notion of planes and models and the idea
is if you want to create a 3d object
then you probably probably need a higher
level of computation but if you're just
transforming a 2d plane then you can
probably get away with doing a little
less that's my demo it works so that's a
great transition so instead of talking
about it I figured it would be a good
idea to just show you what I mean so
we'll see if this works because my
presentation is on a different slide ok
so here we are okay so earlier you might
have noticed that a bunch of these cards
are on your table you can go ahead and
try scan the QR code disclaimer I
haven't tested this on all mobile
devices just my own and it was still a
little janky so definitely try it out
but you can also try it out on your
laptop it might be smoother you can just
go to cure a r-j Escom so I'm going to
go ahead and open up the first demo
which is this guy
okay so what this is doing right now is
its use the getusermedia in order to
pull the video video feed from the
browser and then once it had that it
added it to the screen using a canvas
you see some glitching it's not perfect
yet but what this is doing is now it's
overlaying my r2d2 on top of this
remember that example that we looked at
earlier where r2d2 is projecting a
hologram we're going to try it and go
ahead and recreate that using curare rjs
so the first step is we need to create a
3d model in order to create a 3d model I
used a software called blender so
basically so what I did was a user in
order to create this model it's kind of
cute if you look at it when it's stable
I basically just took a sphere and a
cylinder join them together then I use
something called the texture paint in
order to paint on top of it you can go
ahead and download an actual model off
of a lot of different websites there are
a lot of sites that offer free models
that you can use but in essence there's
two main pieces to the model
there's the object file and the material
file so the object file basically says
this is what the 3d object is and the
object fell is dictated by a set of
vertices so for example in the case of
r2 you had points alongside everywhere
on the sphere you notice that it wasn't
perfectly round this is in order to
optimize for performance the fewer
vertices there are the less vector math
you have to do the second piece of the
puzzle is the material file and what the
material file says is given this image
or the given this image how do you map
it on top of the object let's take a
look at those now so if I go ahead and
open up my console should be able to
show you this guy so this is my
beautiful painting of r2d2 so if you
look at all this code is on github by
the way I'll show you that in a second
but this is the so this is the texture
map that it's using and so the material
file says given this image how do you
wrap it around this model object okay so
what does the code look like for this
I'm using the cure AR 3d library and
I've can you guys see this in the back
can you give me a thumbs up okay cool
so what I'm doing here is I'm using the
the QR Air library first I need to use
three J s the cute the library takes in
a three J s object so you can pass in
whatever you want you can create
multiple different objects and group
them together if that's what you want to
transpose on this plane but it son
opinionated about that so you need a
dependency on three the three object
loader and the three material loader
lastly over here I'm importing the QR AR
library itself so it's on unpackaged so
you don't have to use npm fee if you're
kind of just in the browser but if you
are an NPM you can just npm install that
once we have that this is all the code
it takes in order to write this so first
we're getting three this is just a
selector the important code is over here
first we're creating a material loader
and an object loader once we have that
we're saying load all the materials from
this asset path load the r2d2 MTL file
which is a material file and once these
are pre-loaded set it on the object then
load the r2d2 object file and once we
have that we will have a 3GS object
which we can pass into QRA our 3d the
only line of code that you really need
from the library is this one right here
you just call QRA rjs qra our 3d passing
the library three Jas and then you need
to pass in the root element so this is
where it'll go ahead and add this whole
overlay so it'll go ahead and request
for user media then create a canvas and
add the video overlay this is telling it
about how big your marker is in the
physical world so in this case it's
about 10 centimeters so 100 millimeters
you need this because when you transpose
a marker in the real world
you need to know how much to rotate it
by in the virtual world so you need the
size of the actual physical marker next
you pass in the object and lastly you
pass in a scale of the object in this
case the object was kind of small when I
exported it so I just bumped it up by 20
and that's pretty much it once you have
this your AR will go in find the div
that's passed in in this case to our AR
3d and if we look at it in the elements
panel you'll see that it added two
things this canvas is the three j/s
canvas so this is the WebGL canvas that
it renders the model on top of and the
second thing that it added is this video
so that it streams the video from the
webcam feed and once you have all of
this you can just put this in front of
it and rotate it around and that's
pretty much it so in a few lines of code
you're able to add a 3d model to your
application it automatically detects the
QR code and it's able to transpose the
image on top of it you don't have to
worry about any of that vector math and
all you really need to do is just create
the 3d model that you want to pass in
and configure it I want to show you
another demo so this one is using the
two D transpose method so if you go to a
QR AR 2d HTML this is just a flat image
and once it loads you'll see that is
transposing this image on top of this
object let's take a look at what this
looks like so I mentioned earlier that
there's the two different with two
different types of models the 3d model
of where you want to create a like a
whole 3d object and you want to put it
in the scene and secondly the 2d plane
so this is like for example if you
wanted to replicate something like paper
or a menu item that you wanted to click
around in now one thing that kind of
frustrated me when I used react 360 is
that it doesn't actually support HTML a
regular jeaious JSX
you have to write specific components
texts or VR buttons in order to create a
panel so what I did here was using the
same principles as the three of the 3d
model it's a little glitchy so bear with
that but the code is really simple in
order to set this up we just need one
line of code that's it
QR a rjs here are a are 2d it takes in
three things one is the root element
similar to the 3d version the second is
the size of the marker again same as the
previous version and the less is it
takes an HTML element so you can pass in
any HTML element in this into this in
this case we're passing in this panel
and all the panel has is this image
asset logo but this could have anything
in the world it could have text it could
have men you could have a whole react
app or an iframe and what it does under
the hood is it goes in and it uses the
same the same math in order to figure
out what the transpose it is and then it
uses CSS transforms in order to overlay
the HTML element on top of that QR code
what this means is that we don't need a
like a WebGL canvas so we're saving a
lot of computational power there it also
means that if you already have something
that you kind of want to throw together
really quickly then it's easy to do if
you've ever dealt with like trying to
add just a simple image and threw it in
like the 3d world you know that it's
like a huge pain in the butt this is way
easier right you just need an HTML
element and you can pass in whatever you
want to it and so with this one line of
code you can create a flat panel in this
3d space that's pretty much all you need
and if you look at what it generates all
it has is this is the panel that we're
passing in hey I wonder if this works I
could probably edit it I haven't tried
this let's see if that works so if I add
high on there
you can see that you can barely see it
but it's at the top of the je s so like
anything that you want in there so you
can imagine what you could imagine some
of the possibilities here if you if you
were to use something like this then you
could create things like an additional
menu or for example say you I'm just
making this up but say you have a
business card and you want to have like
a add me on LinkedIn button you could
totally do that it's just a website
right um ok cool
so with that I'll go back to my slides
ok so just to recap we looked at two
different demos one was the QR a our 3d
version in order to get this to work all
you need to do is first import the
library import the 3 J s dependencies
and then you can use it in your code
over here the only line of code from the
library that you need to use is QR a rjs
doc you are a are 3d you pass in the
three library route elements the size of
the scale and lastly the object and the
object and the scale of the object for a
QR AR 2d what you can do is you just
need to again import the library and
create an element called panel and or it
doesn't have to be called panel just
create an HTML element and then you pass
in three things the route which is where
the whole thing gets the video and
everything gets added the second is the
marker size and lastly it's the HTML
panel that you want to transpose on top
of it
the interesting thing here is you can
combine the two as well so let me go
back to my demo so this is the one that
you guys are probably seen earlier but
if you go to index.html you will see
that I've recreated that r2d2 message
over here you have this you have the
bots and you have both the 3d and the 2d
overlaid on on the same transpose this
is just a simple example but you could
imagine you can do anything with this if
I hit this will play a sound I think my
computer is muted but you guys kind of
heard it earlier so so yeah okay now let
me go back to my slides one more time
sorry about that okay so you can combine
pure air 3d and 2d and if you want to
use this as of an hour ago it's on NPM
under QRA rjs so feel free to download
it try it out let me know what you think
it's also on unpackage and on github
also stuff that I did today is also
going to be on github so you can use it
as examples if you want to build your
application so that's curiae rjs and how
you can use it with a few lines of code
lastly I want to talk to you about the
next steps with QRA rjs and what
augmented what's in store for augmented
reality in the web so let's talk about
how curare rjs works it's kind of it
boils down to these few steps so first
we need to get the users media so this
gets the video stream from the user in
order to analyze this right now and post
putting it on a canvas because there's
no way to get image data directly from a
stream so once we have the image data
all that is is a giant array of all of
the pixels this gets passed into the
marker locator in our case the marker is
a QR code and what it does is given an
image it returns the four corners of the
QR code those four corners get passed
into something called the pose estimator
so it turns out this is actually a very
challenging problem if you have an image
of if you have any image and you have
four points on that image on a flat 2d
image figuring out what the three D
transpose was in order to create that
it's actually a very
some problem to solve and especially
when those four points are coplanar so
they're all in the same plane
you can't 100% be certain what the 3d
rotation is so earlier you saw some
glitches that's because of that but
there are some algorithms out there that
can that can improve that a bit and
lastly once you get the post so the pose
is the rotation and the transform
transpose so for example like the how
many degrees it's rotated in each angle
and how far along in each XY and Z plane
it is moved along those get passed into
the 2d view render and the 3d view
render and what those do is those then
create the 2d view and then the 3d view
depending on whether you want a plane or
a model so before we talk about some
improvements let's quickly recap on the
event loop so the event loop if you can
think of this as the event loop
javascript is single threaded so it can
only ever do one thing at a time what
this means is if you're executing code
it can't render you can the so it's
called a loop so oh you can see my mess
um so the process the process goes
around in the circle and it has a few
different things that needs to do in
order to re-render the sight style
layout and paint just to oversimplify a
bit so every time you render something
on the page it goes through the cycle
now what happens if you have to perform
a task say looping through an array of
4,000 pixels what it does is when it's
performing this task it can't go in and
render your render your scene so what
this means is that your scene will seem
kind of janky and that's kind of that's
that's where I'm at with the library
right now what you and the other thing
is it can also only the browser can
decide whether it performs the tasks or
skips it and/or performs the render or
not so what you can do in order to
alleviate some of this is use things
like a web worker a web worker is a way
to add a secondary thread to your
JavaScript right now all we've been
using is the UI thread but you can spin
up a web worker thread this is similar
to service workers if you've heard of
that term
for and what it does is it takes your
tasks and does the processing on that
thread I tried to use this for the
project and what I found out was that
right now there's a bug where there's a
huge secure the vulnerability with
shared memory buffers and so in order to
share memory from one thread to the
other you have to serialize it down to
like a string and then deserialize it
and so when dealing with really large
images this ended up being slower like
the serializing and deserializing ended
up being slower than just processing it
on the main thread but I expect that to
change in the future another thing that
you can do to improve this performance
is to use something like web assembly if
you use something like web assembly then
what it does is it makes it faster to
process tasks this is because all of
your JavaScript is already compiled so
it doesn't have to interpret it when
it's running again I tried to look into
web assembly and one of the libraries I
looked at it was assembly script all of
the code I have right now is written in
typescript an assembly script is a
library that allows you to take
typescript and transpile it down to web
assembly however using this I learned
that assembly script isn't exactly
typescript it's a subset of it and so I
would have to get rid of a lot of my
classes or custom types in order to use
it but that might be another optimation
optimization to do in the future so the
two places that we can optimize are with
the marker locator and the pose
estimator for the marker locator I base
it off of this library called jsq R
which is a pure JavaScript library that
detects the QR code but you could
imagine that if there was a more
efficient library that was say written
in rust or C we could use web assembly
in order to you in order to use that a
faster functionality the second one is
Poe's estimator so this is the thing
that I explained earlier that given the
four corners on a 2d image it's actually
quite complicated to get the 3d
transpose of it and in order to get this
to work I used I based it off of jsr
reco turned out that that library had a
few bugs in it already so that's why
some of the stuff that I was seeing was
not exactly right but one optimization
in his future was would be to maybe like
move off the pose estimator code off to
a web worker because that way it frees
up space for your render
cycle and if you guys are interested
this is all on github I currently has
two contributors but if you know
anything about WebGL or vector math feel
free to contribute to it or just check
it out
so I really believe that the future of
augmented reality for the web is what we
make of it I think that going along
there's a lot of different libraries
that are have popped up in the past and
that will continue to pop up in order to
do AR in the browser so with that being
said I want to leave you with this
question
why do you love JavaScript my favorite
thing about JavaScript is that I love it
because of its reach and its versatility
writing applications in JavaScript is
easy because you don't need to set up a
whole development environment anyone can
do it it's very easy to write JavaScript
in the script tag in an HTML page on the
browser I'm really excited about this
prospect because it means that we can
allow anyone that's a really beginner to
programming to build things like
augmented reality and this is just
scratching the surface there's so many
new technologies that are coming to
JavaScript and to the web land
especially with things like web
assemblies so for example like
tensorflow j/s is now a thing so you can
run machine learning in the browser and
I think it'll keep growing the mobile
web is powerful enough to run for
virtual and augmented reality today and
everyone already has the mobile device
so I invite you to build the future of
augmented reality together thank you
you